it's a great pleasure to welcome Tom
Barrett to Stanford as our keynote
speaker for the 2008 principle investing
conference Tom don't move it move it
they're like to move but what we're
seeing the only thing that I can say I'm
George's introduction is clear I can't
keep a job
first of all I I can't tell you what a
thrill it is for me to be introduced by
George because we we've shared two
boards for a decade and I've learned so
much from you as has the management on
the the companies whose boards we we
serve George has this way of allowing
all the titans of industry who are ego
battling around the table you've all
seen this this amazing psychic phenomena
that takes place
normal people walk into a boardroom and
turn into maniacs and George sits
quietly listening to the presentation
and there's always a CFO and a CEO who
have in the back of their mind this one
question they pray nobody ever asks and
when George drops those glasses and
starts with the words could you explain
they all dive under the table for cover
he has a amazing ability to do that when
I was asked to to be here today I was I
was thrilled of course because it's a
privilege to speak at schools that had
returned my admissions application
unopened many years ago
so I'm really honored but I was I was I
was trying to think of what would be
interesting and what could I contribute
to an otherwise unbelievably formidable
group of panelists and speakers who are
following and I decided the best thing I
could do is to find something that I may
know a little bit more than they know
and I was unable to think of anything
except maybe surfing and and I want to
get I want to give you just the the
framework of what I'm going to talk to
you about is really not the stuff it's
it's the tools that you need to be able
to work and implement this stuff which
as years have gone on when we look at
what are what are the what are the real
differences between alpha and beta what
are the real attributes of what all of
you who are in school today are going to
need in the work force and what all of
you who are in the work force need is a
competitive tool it ends up being that
you've got to have the clubs in your bag
right you you you need to find a
discipline and then you need to start
working on the tools and the golf course
will change the sand traps will change
the fairways will change but but the
tools that you develop over time will be
what you which are able to utilize so in
thinking of a theme I have I have three
sons all of whom surf so for me to spend
father-son bonding time with them it's a
mile out at sea
and terrifying circumstances and this
last Christmas one of my son's is a
professional surfer and we were out in
Hawaii surfing and he and his in his
professional pals were telling all the
amateurs who had been surfing in five
six seven foot waves that there was a
swell coming up and they should go in at
this particular spot that we were
surfing of course as is the case nobody
ever listens and the swells start
building and all this and I'm looking
I'm looking
how to see I'm paddling out and I see
the sky just go dark and this rogue set
starts rolling in there's a whole series
of 3040 people caught in this impact
zone and three or four people paddling
up behind it
needless to say what happens is that
this rogue wave hits
shatters the boards and the leashes
those boards and leashes go flying and
everybody in the aftermath is diving for
cover and for five minutes you didn't
know if anybody survived I mean
literally you didn't know if anybody
survived and what came to mind at that
moment after I found my son washed up on
somebody else at surf board and
everything had calmed down was that this
is where we are this is the moment that
we're in today this is what opportunity
fund investing is like so what I'm going
to talk to you about is just some
characteristics of great investors many
of whom you're going to hear today and
then I'm going to give you tidbits of of
of what our view is what our point of
view is where we are in the world
that'll be like an anchovy on a Caesar
salad you know that the rest of the
speakers in the panelists this afternoon
will be the lettuce and they can look at
us as the anchovy some of you may like
it and leave it on and some of you may
toss it away but first of all
opportunity fund investor you the
limited partners who are here will tell
you that they make their money and asset
allocation that the decision of where
the money goes is the most important
decision they make so whether whether
you allocate to equities whether you
allocate to fix income or the allocate
to alternative investment that that
major decision is where you really make
your money and then within that within
that tiny tier everybody has an
expertise ours happens to be produce
extraordinary return and people would
like to tell you that you can produce
extraordinary return without
extraordinary risk that's a fallacy it's
impossible all returns regress to the
mean professor Parker taught you that in
finance 101 it doesn't work that way you
have to find extraordinary risk but you
have to practice extraordinary risk and
that's the key so in our business the
ingredients to produce extraordinary
returns is be prepared and master how to
take and find extraordinary risk and
that's that's really what we've done and
it's exactly analogous to to surfing I'm
going to show you it isn't like just a
clip it's not a game this isn't a joke
it's not like just something that you
just go out and do it this is something
that's
it's serious this is life-threatening
every second and and I think personally
it's incredible to see the lack of
appreciation for the power of this wave
there's a lot of jockeying going on I
can see everybody's just looking towards
the rides you know they can't even see
that the left didn't exist at pe'ahi so
the sets come around I looked there and
I go ahead just set me up with the left
I don't care about the right so I take
off on this left and all Center was much
calmer and there was a bit of just
quietness
it was like now we were able to separate
herself because for a while like the
last couple years is with all these
people coming and now on touching point
where it's so chaotic such a circus that
we could detach ourselves from it in a
way you know is funny I felt more safe
with all the sharks over on the left
side than with all the people over on
the right side that's summarize that's
into my presentation right it says
everything when you're in the middle of
the crowds the tailwind has been right
on our fanny so for the last 10 years
all of us have been brilliant why
because the momentum has just been
carrying us upward only and the packs
and the amateurs join in that phenomenon
and to separate yourself from that pack
to get to get out of the way is the key
and I think the last comment was was
really brilliant that he felt more
comfortable with the sharks on the left
than he did in the notion of the harness
security on the right because we all
love to invest in packs especially those
of us were reporting to limited limited
partners these limited partners have to
rely on consultants consultants have to
rely on information information is a
commodity right I mean we like to say
that there's information arbitrage there
is no information arbitrage you go to
the most prestigious school in the world
Stanford you have a question that you
want answered without analytical ability
just facts
you push Google and the kuda graduated
from Culver High has the same
information that has taken you eight
years to get so if you think information
is going to be the edge I have bad news
for you it isn't going to work you look
at once you've graduated two big waves
it's like once you've graduated out of
Business School you've got to assume
everybody's great everybody is great and
I have bad news for you when you
graduate from Business School it starts
all over again
that heap just keeps waving the cream
goes to the top now you have a new Kadri
of people they're all good they're all
talented and that competitive set starts
all over again so in order to
distinguish yourself you have a number
of things that you need to do harder
work more preparation
more risk quicker risk analysis take the
left instead of the right a combination
of all of those things but you have to
distinguish yourself with something and
terror along the way is a good thing
it's a healthy thing to be complacent to
have hubris is is is essential that as
you're looking at an investment as we
look at investments or as we look at our
great peers most of people who you're
going to talk to this afternoon what
they know is where the exit is before
the entrance what they develop over time
is an instinct about it not so much the
informational analytical ability of
where it is we're going to talk a little
later about themes about developing
themes and what happens mostly is great
investors who develop the theme after
the instinct they don't create the theme
and go out in the world and try and find
the theme and we're going to we're going
to talk about that in depth but it's
about taking risk not avoiding risk
especially an opportunity fund investing
it's it's the key anticipation is
everything it's it's those years of
knowledge and wisdom of wandering
through those jungles to find elephants
and tigers and giraffes that perhaps you
weren't looking for that all go to this
Kadri of experiential stuff that when
you go to draw on is there and and being
quick on that trigger and being able to
adapt instantly to change your point of
view which is why when I say it's it's
the tools in your gut and your golf bag
it's not so much the golf course it's
the key because it goes from a sand trap
to a green and an instant and if you're
invested in just hitting out of sand
traps and there's not a sand trap there
you're in big trouble avoiding crowded
takeoffs humility all those things we've
talked about before it's it's really the
key and adaptability and cultural $0.06
I think one of the most essential
ingredients for any great private equity
investor is that is their ability to be
able to sense the culture we talk about
globalization the globalization is
interpreted by little tiny nodes of
localization
so understanding the fabric of what
they're in of what they're doing where
they're going is the key you know a lot
of this is obvious but showing respect
to those around you and then demanding
respect is a very delicate balance
because humility unless unless you are
the number one smartest person in the
field that you're in you can be
unfriendly you can be not nice you can
be arrogant and you'll probably succeed
if you're the number two or three then
you better learn those other attributes
these people have to like you you have
to figure out how to express your talent
and ability how to be able to use it so
getting getting into this place where
you're extending your own comfort zone
if you extend it too little you can't
compete if you extend it too much you're
dead
so harnessing this this adaptability
this risk tolerance is one of the
toughest things opportunistic versus
strategic you know this is a moment and
you're going to be talking about it all
day where no matter what anybody tells
you nobody has any idea what's happening
every hour is a different situation and
the truth is it doesn't matter what's
happening what matters is that you have
a focus and a point of view as to how to
handle the volatility but most investors
go out and create a theme so they get a
Kadri of brilliant business school and
law school grads put them in a room say
come up with where you think the world
is going they spend hours and days and
weeks creating a theme then they take
that theme they march out in the world
and try and get the world to align with
their theme and once you get invested in
that theme you're not paying attention
so much to the other things that are
happening around you because you're
trying to confirm the theme that you
spent so much time and so much effort
and so much money investing in we're
really what happens at a time like this
is you need to be themelis you need to
react to all those little test tubes
that are floating by you without a point
of view just looking for that
experiential arbitrage there's a great
book by the way for any
you haven't read it Nicholas tail that
also happens to be Lebanese which who
I'm a little prejudiced so you know
loyalty to ideas is is a very difficult
thing and we all talked about thinking
outside the box I don't think thinking
outside the box does a thing you have to
live outside the box you have to have a
set of experiences that have nothing to
do with your primary business purpose
it's why for those of you who are
motivated by money if you go and talk to
300 of the wealthiest people in the
world I guarantee you 299 of them will
tell you they were never concerned with
money money isn't what drove them their
money isn't what got them their money
wasn't their motivation it was a passion
for something else money happened to be
the other result of what it was and so
this Renaissance ability if you look at
every great investor in private equity
they're all Renaissance men or women
they all have some unique factors some
very interesting categories they're all
involved in bizarre things because all
of those other life experiences bring a
point of view that's much more flexible
than being an alpha manager to public
equities and I'm not down grading that
at all the fact that public managers
haven't beat the S&P index for any
10-year period since the beginning of
time has nothing to do with it which is
true by the way some common-sense things
you know especially when you're in
school long line relationships when
you're building relationships because
you need them they hardly ever work
because the world is too transparent so
when you're out concentrating on a
networking on cultivating on building
relationships it's oh it's always very
difficult but if you make that a life
practice over time that karma bank
builds builds up and the great investors
especially in the private equity world
have spent decades building and
collecting those relationships and they
draw on them over a period of time
the the accessibility of you to them or
of them to transactions is also an
unbelievable factor is the most powerful
people I've found over time are the
easiest to get to its inversely
proportionate to what you would think
it's absolutely true you want to call
Warren Buffett this afternoon and tell
him what a wonderful magnanimous thing
it was that he did to bid on the
municipal bond portfolio the bond
insurers and to leave them with the CDOs
and the CD X's you'll get him on the
phone within 2 or 3 hours you want to
get the vice president of AIG it'll take
you four days just the way that it works
you know after a great education one
piece of advice is what happens is like
racehorses you train thoroughbreds on a
track with other thoroughbreds so you're
very careful that they don't get kicked
you want to put them in separate
paddocks you want to make sure that
they're brushed and polished two times a
day you feed them separately and then
you take them to a track it's like
ultimate fighting right you bring a and
a prize boxer who's only been with
boxers and you put him in a ring with a
jujitsu Brazilian maniac and the rules
change
so this prize boxer doesn't know what
just happened to him he's on he's on his
back he's on the ground and somebody's
using another set of rules well after a
great education this is what happens
when you go out into the world so you
have to without losing your ethics get
to that edge again you have to retrain
yourself to risk you have to train
retrain yourself to the street a bit and
take all those great tools and use them
in a more adaptable form this I think
summarizes the use of information this
is what we find in our organization
which is the information you have is not
the information you want the information
you want is not the information you need
the information you need is not the
information you can get and the
information you get everyone has
so we sit there after months and months
of analysis and due diligence and this
is where we always end up everybody has
the same information so you know you go
to auctions this is this is this is what
I love i you know Wall Street is so
amazing because we all resisted going to
auctions so now we have art you know our
teams will walk in bidding on on
companies against Morgan Stanley Goldman
Sachs TPG Blackstone Carlyle KKR the
toughest smartest investors in the world
and come out high five and this was
awesome we want we just paid the highest
price over the smartest investors in the
world what could be smart about this
right it just it's counter to it doesn't
make any sense
all the training that I've done with
Laird and Derek and Brett and the strap
crew and the windsurfing and everything
I've done to this point has helped
prepare me for a bad situation and to
enjoy what I am being given the rides
the waves you know it's not just a
matter of surviving but it's a matter of
writing and and performing a lot of
these people have skipped a lot of steps
because they want to go out and ride
this wave and I can understand why it's
a it's to draw it's exciting it's a
sense of accomplishments all these
things but I think that might be taking
some some unnecessary risks you can't
cheat that many steps and think that
you're you're going to be able to pull
it off for that long and I think that's
the bottom line message is you can't
cheat the process it's it's time in the
saddle when it when a when is it your
back momentum looks everything it makes
everything look great the wind is now on
our head it's a different time and those
who took the shortcuts made it look
simple will have a difficult time what I
thought I do now is is take ten minutes
and just give you our view of the world
I think we circulated at Chairman's
corner that gave you a more in-depth
view of the useless information that we
can provide on where things are because
of course we don't know any better than
anybody else and then we'll have time
for questions and answers but you know
the long and the short of it is that
markets are very predictable is all
accesses regress to the mean
but before they regress to the mean they
revert to the other excess and that
pendulum swings back and forth and we're
in the middle of a pendulum swing and
nobody's quite sure where it's going and
the pendulum swing started as an excess
driven by accounting as it's always
driven and the analogies between 1990
which was a time before
most of you were born and at that time
by the way I had blonde hair and blue
eyes I was devastating it was it was
amazing before we got into this silly
business and and and now and the
similarities are very are very close in
that what would drove the demise of the
Savings and Loan industry in 1990 was a
regulatory realignment of the industry
it took an industry that was was a
boring mortgage origination business and
turned it into a hot financial business
driven by capital regulatory
requirements and accounting and that's
virtually what's happened now with
securitization and derivatives is banks
who have already a very low capital
regulatory requirements so for every
dollar of capital you can borrow against
it ten dollars in the box and $90 out of
the box when you get that off-balance
sheet with a derivative you increase
that leverage a hundred times so as all
good businessmen do using the tools they
have in the in accounting instruments
that they've got in an upward only
market they started creating more and
more products and they started to find
more and more animals that wanted to eat
the product and they created products to
meet that animal and and ratings a
triple-a rating only provides a capital
arbitrage because if you're an insurance
company or a foreign bank and you buy a
triple-a rated piece of paper you have
no capital charge on that investment
where if I buy a whole loan instead of
that securitized piece of paper I have a
capital charge or three or four dollars
against that dollar of capital so what
happened was nothing wrong just the
financial industry doing what it does
best which is carving and creating these
products moving a lot of balance sheet
so they had more capital feeding the
animal with the animal wanted to eat in
an upward wind only environment you know
that's what happens but the difference
between 1990 and now is it was very
simple when you hit a crisis which you
always find and the crisis was you had a
borrower you knew who the borrow was you
had a lender you knew the lender was you
had a piece of collateral you knew where
it was and you had a series of
resolutions you could foreclose on it
you could have a discounted
payoff you could restructure the loan
now all of you are in the wrong school
if you wanted to figure out how to solve
derivatives you need to be in the
nuclear physics department I don't know
if any of you have ever read I'm sure
some of you have an actual description
of some of the sophisticated CDOs and
ciello structures you need Inspector
Clouseau to try and figure out what's
going on and as a special servicer
responsible to then now remember none of
this we haven't gotten to default we're
not talking about defaults we're talking
about fair value accounting does anybody
here an accountant
does anybody here understand for value
accounting nobody does now the smartest
students and alumni in the world I'm
telling you no one understands for value
accounting including the accounts and
that's why what you're going to see with
the banks is this continual meltdown
because there's no possible way of
marking the market long term liabilities
and assets in the manner in which we're
doing so on top of that you have this
bond insurer meltdown the bond insure
meltdown
everybody's looking to well look what
having to magic today look what's
happening to am back look what's
happened to FDIC no problem you can have
all the bond insurers go broke and at
the holding company the bond insurers
it's not such a big problem there's only
one problem is underneath that you have
189 billion of guaranteed debt that's
held in other banks so when societe
Generale's debt I mean is this was one
of the greatest thing I love America you
watch CNBC after this kid by the way you
want to hire this kid anybody who could
figure out how to do seven point nine
billion right I mean this would this was
a feat this is this wasn't some small
little task and all the commentators
come out and say this is the greatest
thing that ever happening on amis
healthy because they didn't lose the
money in derivatives they lost it on
fraud it's unbelievable so the real
problem Societe Generale is am back and
FDIC have seventy six billion of rated
society's general debt against forty
billion of capital so downgrade just
puts them gone they're just gone it's
just history
so and we could talk on about you know
we talked about Warren Buffett's offer
on I'm buying the municipal portfolio
it's a smart business move for him it
makes no sense for those companies so
you have this banking problem which is
write down but that's not really the
problem of what's happened the problems
what happens what do they do for
revenues so you're taking write downs
they're trying to look in their rearview
mirror and say okay we've got all these
problems we need to fix the problems in
the meantime there's no IPO business
there's no M&A business there's no
mortgage business you'll see some of the
big investment banks get out of the
securitization business altogether and
you could see this being the beginning
of the end of triple-a rated securities
and we can talk about that more later
what is the purpose of a triple-a rating
from groups who have proved themselves
to be totally unreliable totally
unreliable in every instance and the
market will react to this over time the
coupling and decoupling and you're going
to have a globalization panel with
people who are much smarter than I our
point of view is absolutely everything
is coupled there's no such thing as
decoupling so when you increase the
consumers ability to buy in America the
flip and I were talking about it before
you might as well just write the Chinese
to check don't give the American
consumer the cheque just send it to
China because that's where it's going to
end up so the reliance of everybody on
everybody
and in this soup is there to stay the
all of the governmental intervention
it's the same thing that it was in the
90s it only postpones the inevitable the
inability for the American government
just to let the market take care of this
flush at all
let the foreclosures go to foreclosures
let the bankruptcies go to bankruptcies
and the market will mark itself to
market in an instant you know project
lifeline allowing all of these
foreclosures 30 more days and poor Hank
Paulson is one of the most brilliant
guys in the world he couldn't even read
his script you know he was so disgusted
with himself as he's reading
there's this new brilliant Bush proposal
it's unbelievable the Fed intervention
the fiscal package it's all just
postponing the inevitable and in fact
you see it in the market because all of
these things are supposed to instill
confidence and what happens is mortgage
rates go up Hillary Clinton comes and
says well great we'll just put a
moratorium on interest rates for four
years it'll be great nobody'll have a
mortgage on the house in the world right
you'll just destroy the mortgage market
in its entirety so it's it's a tough
time sovereign funds I mean with what's
happened is if you look at Citigroup for
instance internal cost of capital about
two percent they need a capital in an
afternoon they go to to foreign fund
investors they get the money at nine to
eleven percent without the sovereign
fund of course Americans are yelling oh
my god we're being taken over by the
Arabs but let's pay them another
trillion dollars a year in windfall
petrol dollars for the oil that we have
you know where you all should be we all
should be in Dubai right now with
Stanford University of Dubai how many
how many of you bender Dubai is it the
most amazing phenomenon you've ever seen
in your life it's incredible it'll
probably be a disastrous ugly ending but
at the moment all of the money in the
world is going there Abu Dhabi is the
richest per capita country in the world
and no matter what we do we're sending
our dollars there and trying to recycle
them here so who owns all the debt of
America we have 13 trillion in debt the
Arabs the Chinese and the Japanese and
we're worried about intervention of them
taking a total position in one of our
banks we're not worried about them
owning the nine trillion of debt or the
five trillion of the stock market and
mortgage market that we have today it's
in Congress we want them to open their
markets to us and we want to close our
markets to them
the bottom line I think our take through
this is it's not a liquidity confidence
crisis its countenance a confidence
crisis and this distribution channel of
how financial product gets disseminated
in the regulatory environment which is
hold is is really really in trouble so
you know what are the best places to
invest it
our view is the greatest long investment
is America if you look at the dollar
against every other currency it's cheap
it's going to stay cheap there's no
other solution the dollar has to remain
getting pounded what happens when that
happens is inflation and inflation will
rage as it always rages so if you look
at all these ingredients of an emerging
market the u.s. is probably the best
emerging market if you look at all of
the emerging markets that people have
talked about before and you're going to
have a lot presented to you this
afternoon about China and India China
and India obviously for growth or place
that you need to be it's hard to find
Westerners that have actually exited
those markets with money those are two
very sophisticated places with very
sophisticated and investors that don't
really need capital the difference
between the two is in India you have an
average tenure of a real estate
development company of two years but
every graduate speaks English so every
graduate from India gets on an airplane
with a package of a Township that they
want to promote to some US entity in
China you have hardly anybody that
speaks English and you have development
companies that have been there for 25
years so nobody gets on an airplane
coming here with a package to present to
a u.s. investor either way none of the
US investors in in massive terms have
done very well in those markets the
markets that are starting to explode are
the Middle Eastern Russia very difficult
to penetrate takes a long a long time to
build those relationships and it's a
little bit counterintuitive but I think
you're going to be short Japan China
Korea long the US Middle East and Russia
will continue to be dominant places
amazed the amazing thing in the middle
of all this is the general economy is
actually quite good a lot of you
probably saw the retail numbers that
came out of the fourth fourth quarter
retail numbers are great Walmart Home
Depot or up it's incongruity of what's
going on so I think the bottom line is
nobody has any idea what's really
happening and the good news for
investors which I think you're going to
hear through throughout the day is
America's resilient the investors who
are going to speak to you today are
amongst the smartest in the best that
have the mobility to move through these
volatile markets and as long as there's
volatility there's tremendous
opportunity to be had we've kind of
talked about all this in the parade's of
horrible which you're going to you're
going to hear during the day the
trickle-down effect the reason I think
this is so much deeper I was listening
to a lot of the commentary this morning
they're saying it's over the shorts are
off everything is fine
go out and spend again I was looking for
Jim Herbert first republic' to get
another jumbo loan on a new house I
think it's all garbage I think when when
the March results are in when this
quarter is in it's going to be a
disaster and that trickle-down effect
when you start really getting to
defaults you haven't gotten to default
you know you're going to hear you've got
some of the of the best LBL and private
equity investors here this afternoon
there's challenges you can't pay a 20%
premium to a company that was it as
historic high put five times leverage on
it have the market then evaporate 30% of
your market cap value and say
everything's great it's not going to be
great cielos ceos CMBS RMBS all
challenged as that moves through the
system there's going to be huge problems
sometimes when the water is too
turbulent you have to concentrate on
something easily
and this is it
so I think my last minister do and then
we'll have some questions is you know
every every morning a lion wakes up in
the jungle and knows that it has one
thing to do it's got to run faster than
the slowest gazelle and every gazelle
wakes up it knows one thing that to
survive it has to run faster than the
fastest lion so whether you're a lion or
a gazelle you better get up and start
running that's the bottom line
Thanks
we've got about 15 minutes or so for
questions yes sir say that or you know
or you simply deal with it the the the
question is that yeah I've said going to
auction you you feel foolish
and since auctions have been the vehicle
of choice for Wall Street in the last
decade what's the solution if auctions
don't work than what is the solution and
I think the answer is in an upward
market auctions work because what
happens is everything you would have
bought in the last ten years and I think
all of us all around these panels today
have to be honest with each other is no
one knows were they brilliant or were
they lucky and the truth is it doesn't
matter right if you're an investor I
mean we're stewards of limited partners
money so as long as we're producing
results whether we were lucky or whether
we were smart is irrelevant so in that
node going to auction when you have all
of this ability when you have these
teams that can actually create value so
you have a financial engineering package
you have an acquisition package you can
compensate management differently you
can increase Eva da you you have an exit
and in the exit in most many of these
instances for the last few years have
been dividend recaps refinancing recaps
right so it's been it's it's we we've
all lived off credit it's just been a
credit arbitrage is that debt has been
cheaper than equity the stock market's
been idiotic right when you think about
it it makes no sense you go out and have
a multiple on a company of equity
investors with the equity and you can
replace that equity with debt 600 basis
points cheaper so I mean this was the
arbitrage so it did make sense because
as long as that debt was available then
the parade of returns could continue now
we have a different situation so even
though it felt awkward at the time it
was
absolutely the smart thing to do because
every CEO of a company would never think
of auctioning and it's of course why are
the CEOs auctioning their companies
because these guys are sitting here
having gone to great business schools
like this managing thousands and
thousands of employees and they're
watching these private equity guys
driving Ferraris going to their homes on
the beach and their options are going
down the tubes because the public equity
market wasn't giving them value as CEOs
for what they're doing so everybody said
well let's jump ship we want to be on
the private equity side so the private
equity guys say great we're going to
make you even richer than you are here's
compensation package here's what you're
going to do here's what the piece of
promote in the market did what it did so
I think that's now changed private
equity will react very quickly there'll
be a new gig on the street less
leveraged a different set of tools just
like they switch to two pipes in two
hold positions there'll be a new set of
financial criteria and they'll take all
the great tools they have of knowing how
to manage knowing how to buy knowing how
to be really more servicing to their
investor base than the public equity can
only when you look at public equities we
said well the reason that you you pay
this liquidity premium because you get
transparency you get a professional
management team you get liquidity we've
proved in the last ten years none of
those things are true there's hardly an
accounting firm left alive right we
thought accounting was the method of
responsibility and transparency what we
found is a five year period every
accounting firm went bust
they went bust because of lawsuits
you're going to see the same thing
happen to Investment Banking
all these people who bought derivatives
I guarantee you that the little sheiks
sitting in Abu Dhabi who is buying 750
billion of these derivatives and never
read the book
you get a blue book Morgan Stanley
Goldman Sachs Citibank and they create a
secondary market they think they're
buying a security now when all of this
slows down and all of a sudden these
lawyers sit down and say you know we
just lost a trillion dollars I guarantee
you the lawsuits that are behind this
are going to make what happen in the RTC
look like nothing so the wave on the
wave on the wave is complicated auctions
will always be there but private equity
figure out something else now because
without debt it's got to be a different
gig yes sir yeah the question is I had
mentioned the Dubai will probably and
badly and what's the rationale for that
number one I'm a big supporter of Dubai
but just to give you a little bit of a
background you have seven arab emirates
that were were a consolidation of seven
tribes that were put together by the
british because you have 300,000
Emiratis 300,000 citizens who are the
richest citizens in the world now as a
result of the british having discovered
oil in abu dhabi which is a separate
fiefdom so the only the only one of the
seven arab emirates that really has
spendable capital from natural resources
is abu dhabi not dubai so dubai in order
to find its own place brilliantly and
shrewdly decided that it would become
the commercial capital of the Middle
East Lebanon was war-torn Cyprus was
inefficient the bureaucracies existed
everywhere else so they went to
Singapore and they basically hired the
Singaporean government and said we want
to create a new country so in 10 years
you have best of class of everything the
best Airport the best hotels the best
golf course is the best tennis courts
the best technology centres the best
everything but
the underpinning of all that has not
been windfall Petro dollars the
underpinning of that has been the sale
of residential commercial property so if
you're an Iranian sitting across the
Straits of Hormuz all of you probably
remember your geography Abu Dhabi sits
on a point three miles across from that
point in the Straits of Hormuz is Iran
so we have Iranian sitting there saying
you know on a bad weekend if Israel
launches a nuclear missile we're going
to have a really tough time swimming
across this three miles to get to Abu
Dhabi
so Dubai said great what we're going to
do is for everybody who buys a million
dollar condo we're going to give you
residents so now you have 300,000
Emiratis and Emirates and you have six
and a half million six and a half
million people employees residents
part-time residents not occupying all
those units so when you look at the
natural element of Dubai it's
unbelievably successful the people are
unbelievably smart the product is
fantastic but the excesses of this
speculative thrust will probably have a
consequence at some point so when I say
a great disaster I'm a believer the
Dubai is there for the long term and Abu
Dhabi of Dubai gets in trouble even
though it's been building on a leveraged
basis Abu Dhabi you know with one day's
pumping can bail out Dubai from all of
its vagaries so I think the Middle East
is here to stay as well as long as
you're burning motor fuel no matter what
we say about alternative energy it's not
really going to make a difference China
in one day burns all the oil that you
can save through every kind of ethanol
or alternative energy manufacturing
process that you want in your
automobiles so when you look on a global
basis it's going to take 30 years to fix
that problem so I meant an awful couple
when I say it's it's an excess it's
there's so much building there's there's
more cranes
in goodbye in China today then
everywhere else in the world times -
it's it's amazing
do you also see it as an opportunity for
colony or it does it not produce the
returns that you required great great
question on infrastructure with the
municipal bond dilemma that
infrastructure is going to be a new
project finance opening is that an
opportunity for colony and the answer is
is yes but it's it's like pulling into a
gas station and needing a different
octane fuel private equity and
opportunity funds have been geared to
20% plus returns and the world is
corrected itself so when a deal walks
into our office in Singapore it doesn't
know what it is it doesn't know is it an
opportunity fund deals and
infrastructure deals at a value-added
deal is it LBO do it just knows it's a
deal and we've all bifurcated ourselves
into these little Chinese menu
alternative asset groups but but what's
happened is is the big guys are all
going to multi-platform so if you look
at Carlyle TPG Blackstone they have a
diversity of fund so their investors can
invest in those funds with just a lower
cost of capital but the deal sourcing
pipeline which is the only place that
you really differentiate yourself
because they're all smart they're all
brilliant they're all great at what they
do it's how they source it so I think
that that that there's a huge
opportunity and infrastructure because
what's going to happen is this arbitrage
of having a bond insurer which gave it
to ratings I mean remember it was
already triple-a rated so now you had a
bond
insurer which was just allowed that
capital regulatory piece of buyers out
in the marketplace will be gone and the
Triple A status itself is threatened so
project finance for all those
municipalities as they're searching is
going to be is going to be a big arena
and will participate will just
participate with a different kind of
fuel it'll be a separate definable fund
but I think what you're going to see is
infrastructure funds will be the flavor
of this year it'll be a great place to
invest yes sir
in the thought process that you went
through to sort of process what was
happening what would look what was the
evolution of your forming the
understanding that the evolution of our
thought process was it started with a
sneak preview at the at the credit
market we had never seen the banks
starting to act the way but this is
before subprime because subprime is a
misnomer subprime was just the peek
under the covers of this redistribution
of credit that had gone on and I think
most of us had realized that the frenzy
of lenders the risk that lenders were
taking as they moved up that loan to
value or as they moved up the multiple
of ebody stream was becoming insane and
the reason was becoming insane is they
weren't keeping on their balance sheet
so as originate and syndicate the
banking business had changed it was no
longer matched assets liabilities it was
create sibs and all of these Kaspar
financing vehicles where they could
create unbelievable exponential profits
without ever hitting their capital Tier
one tier two requirements so I think the
first place that we all started to feel
it was the bank started to back up on
the commitments on our corporate deals
which they hadn't done I mean for the
last decade they had always held our
feet to the fire as to these commitments
and and none of us had ever had any need
to hold them to the fire Inlet what
happened as they started coming back
you've all heard covenant light well we
used to borrow money 10 years ago you
used to borrow money and you had a whole
series of thresholds which you had to
maintain within the operating companies
non-financial defaults so if something
was going wrong in the company the bank
had recourse to you for either more
collateral for asset sales for something
as the competition went on in the
industry they went to covenant light
which all of the negotiators the users
of the product said
we're not going to give you those
covenants lend us the money and we'll
pay you back the money that's that's
what you're going to get and the banks
in the frenzy and the easy distribution
of that product all over the world did
that so I think that the first
indication was we saw the bank's backing
up and then as she started to look
through the system the confusing thing
was the economy was pretty good
everybody's business I think what
everybody will tell you today is all the
private equity guys are going to say
their businesses are fine you don't see
it in the business usually you see it in
the business you see it in the financial
structure the capital structures are
strained and it's not even on the
default structures with the defaults are
all as a result of these downgrades it's
not as a result outside of the
residential mortgage cycle which always
happens right I mean the difference in
the residential mortgage which which we
weren't panicked about we knew
foreclosures were up and home builders
are always a sucker punch and I'm not
offending any home builders but if you
look at what you're buying it's it's
it's the worst manufacturing business in
the world they operated five or six
percent margins right you've got to go
long on real estate out ten years to
have inventory takes you seven years to
get entitlements
you can't build houses manufactured in
advance because you get stuck with
inventory and you're in the cyclic 11:00
flow of the mortgage markets so I don't
think too many people paid attention to
what was going on in the residential
market but no one had any idea of the
far-reaching implications including the
banks by the way the banks did nothing
wrong I mean there's no culpability here
they were manufacturing product that was
being digested by a world who had become
drunk on credit it's it's it's it's what
all of us attend America was the
epicentre of credit consumption and now
what we're doing is we're trying to
retrain ourselves we're all in rehab
right I mean I think everybody here
everybody who's on these panels will
tell you we're all in credit rehab and
it's a difficult thing to digest because
you have you have to teach this pony a
new trick so the analytical process I
think is just have some volatility quite
honestly we were related because it had
been a long time that
dealing with amateurs and amateurs
taking undue risk we're producing higher
returns and when you're being judged in
the same category it's very frustrating
so having a correction is a healthy
thing is a good thing and it produces
another whole set of opportunities which
if you can adapt and you're not trapped
by the prison that you built in the past
can be phenomenal but I think it's still
unfolding anybody who tells you that
they know what's going on it's an
accurate I mean this is going to be very
volatile 2008 very volt yes sir Middle
Eastern money we talked about how there
is massive investment on stock market
but we are may be uncomfortable with
investment coming into the banks over
the long term do you expect there to be
a backlash against foreign investment in
the US equity market parted from the
Middle East or do you expect it to be
the inverse that will be more open to
that unfortunately I think the reality
is there will be a backlash which is the
wrong answer
right I mean which what you love is
through this experience to create a new
bridge of tolerance of this natural
distrust between the East and the West
in that bridge of Tolerance would be
built on on the backs of commercialism
where you don't have any of these
political or religious points of view
but the distrust on both sides is is is
startlingly eminent because the Middle
East there I mean as all of you know
there is no such thing as the Middle
East you you have 50 countries with a
hundred languages and and 300 religions
and they hardly agree on anything they
don't agree on borders they don't agree
on religion they don't agree on language
they don't agree on anything and they
all have different points of view and
they all love America they all love
America and they all love Americans at
the moment many of them are little
confused about America's political
policy to them they didn't go looking
for Citibank they didn't go looking for
UBS
they didn't go looking for any of these
institutions they came to them and they
responded with no governance no board
seats no tools which we've all in the
private equity said are you guys crazy
we'll invest with you but it's too soon
it's a falling knife don't invest at
this point wait another ten minutes
we'll invest with you and we'll bring
with you the tools so they've invested
make it in these entities alongside of
Management right and why did management
go to them instead of us because
management wanted to keep their job
right it's that it's that simple
so my hope is that through this there'll
be another huge bridge of Tolerance
because the the Middle East for the next
ten years we better get used to it and
we better learn how to deal with them
and it's the epicenter of the world for
the financially for for money and
financial matters it's on its third
generation they're getting good they're
smart they're mostly Western educated I
think most of them are well-meaning they
can be great partners but America will
always miss play its hand especially in
the midst of of terrorism and all the
difficult things we're dealing with
Thanks
[Applause]